c
à bientôt à bientôt
entretien
et sinon toi raconte hier soir la file à
ouest france
[ __ ] les gars cette fille elle est
juste s'embrasser pendant des heures est
elle oui y'a communaux pourtant que ça y
est je suis pas fan des doigts et le
matin je suis apporter son petit
déjeuner sur la table comme ça sans
prévenir il choque par les cheveux le
mec il a là le vrai romantique et c'est
pas tout j'ai pris ma guitare je dois
regarder droit dans les yeux
3 4 bam bam des claques sur le cul les
ma faim en parlant que je les prends en
photo là pendant qu'ils dormaient vous
allez me dire des nouvelles oui super
jolie où on a vécu un truc tellement
fort fort fort c'est au fart fort elle
est géniale
il est génial mais tu sais tu dois avoir
hâte de présenter à tes parents c'est
sûr bon niveau q oui non mais j'avoue
que déjà c'est sûr à 100% que mon père
et ma le succès pendant deux heures mon
gars tu es fier de mon coup là
dieu pardonne moi tes potes voile
habituel
je suis assez pudique - comme le nom